انفجار هائل وسط الخرطوم دخان اسود كثيف
يصنع مشهدا قاتما للسودان احتمالاته هي ان
يفوز البرهان في المعركه وتنشق جماعه
حميتي ان يفوز حميدتي ويتبعثر الجيش وتدخل
البلاد حربا اهليه نزاع يستمر لسنوات طوال
بين لا غالب ولا مغلوب يصطلح الطرفان
ويقتسمان الصلاحيات وهو سيناريو الذي
يتمناه السودانيون
الجميع
الحسد من الحسد من الحقد
قد تحسم المعركه عسكريا في بعض المناطق في
السودان لكن الصراع قد يطول بسبب
التقسيمات القبليه والسياسيه لكلا الطرفين
المتنازعين هذا معناه اننا امام مرحله من
الصراع الطويل الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحو لفتره اطول
مما هو يعني يبدو السيناريو الذي يرجوه
السودانيون هو المصالحه يلتقي حميدتي
والبرهان ويتفقان على دمج قوه الدعم
السريع مع القوات المسلحه ليكون للسودان
جيش واحد يحفظ الامن ويلبي امنيات هذا
الطفل الصغير
شايفين الدمر
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات